Next question.
Sir, I am a student of BSC final year. I
am from Andha Pradesh, India. I am from
a Hindu family. Alhamdulillah, I
recently reverted into a Muslim. My
question is how one can know whether his
iman is strong or weak and what steps
should be taken in improving my iman and
if one who listen about the punishment
of hellfire and not feeling afraid of it
but worries about other things what is
the strength of his iman the question
poses that how will a person this
question posed by river and He's asking
that how will a person come to know
whether his iman is strong or weak and
what steps should be taken to improve
the iman and the last part is that if a
person hears and knows about the
punishment hellfire and yet he's not
worried about that and is worried about
the worldly things then what is his
status regarding the first part of the
question that how does one come to know
that is iman is strong a person when he
keeps on following
the teachings of Quran and say hadith.
The more he follows, he realizes that
his iman is strong. For example, when he
goes out, a Muslim knows that she is
wear the hijab. The outside world may
not be doing hijab. She's doing hijab.
You know that the iman is strong. That
we know that people do wrong things.
They cheat. You're not cheating. People
tell lies. You don't lie. You're honest.
And the more you follow the Quran and
say hadith, you come to know iman
strong. How do you increase your iman?
One of the best way to increase your
iman is to read the translation of the
Quran. Read the translation of the
hadith of the beloved prophet wasallam.
Read the s of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Read the s
of the
of the sahabas. When you look at the
lifestyle,
you are empowered. You realize that how
strong they were in Ian and how weak we
are in Ian. So if you read the stories
of the sahabas your iman increases. I'd
like to give you one incidence that once
there was a person who comes and tells
the prophet that the neighbor that is
there is not allowing to build the
boundary wall of the house because the
tree is in between. So the prophet tells
the neighbor that if you give that one
tree and allow him to build his boundary
wall, I will give you a tree in Jenna
and refuses. He doesn't agree. So when
one of the Sahaba Abu Dha he hears about
this, he goes and asked the prophet that
if I get that tree and see to it, give
it to him, will I get a tree in Jenna?
The prophet said yes, why not? So he
goes and tells that neighbor that do you
know who I am? He said no. He says I am
Abu Da who owns the biggest and the most
precious garden of dates in Medadina. It
is of course who does not know you. Then
he says that will you give me this tree
which is coming in between your neighbor
boundary wall and for that in exchange
of that tree I will give you my complete
garden of dates
which is the best in Madina. The man
says are you crazy for my one tree
you'll give me the full garden which is
the best in Madina. He says yes and the
person agrees. Abu Dha comes back home
and tells his wife that today I have
done a great deal, an excellent deal.
The wife asks, "What did you do?" So he
narrates the story about that tree and
he tells his wife that I bought that
tree that will give us a tree in Jenna
in exchange for the full garden that we
have in Madina. So the wife says, "Ah,
what an excellent deal." In today's
world, if suppose you have such a big
garden and you want to buy the tree,
today's wife will tell you, "You're a
fool. Why did you give the full garden?
You would have given 25% of the garden
or you should have given 50% of the
garden." And surely that man would have
agreed. Even if you give 25% of the
garden, he would have given that one
tree. But look at the iman. The wife
says, "Ah, what a deal." That means both
of them, the husband and wife, they
didn't want even an out of doubt that
the person will refuse because they
wanted Jenna and and the hadith tells us
that for the rest of their life they
lived a poor life but they lived a very
happy life because they know that the
prophet had promised them paradise. So
if you hear the stories of the Sabbath,
how they lived, how they sacrificed, how
they helped each other, your iman
increases. And it gives us the feeling
that what we are doing is nothing.
Nothing. And we know that at the time of
jihad when the prophet told the Sabbath
that what you want you contribute and
Omar may Allah be pleased with him comes
and he gives the large wealth to the
prophet and the prophet asks him that
what have you left home. So he says I
have left half my wealth at home and
half I'm giving charity for jihad. After
that later on Abu Bakr may Allah be
pleased with him. He comes and he gives
his wealth to the prophet and the
prophet asks him what have you left
home. So he said I have given all my
wealth and I've left Allah and his
rasool at home to take care of us.
Imagine what iman imagine giving his
complete wealth in the way of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala. When you hear these
stories, it it increases our iman. It
makes us feel so small that we can't
even contribute to the cause of Allah
subhanaa tala. We can't even give
charity. If you read the lifestyle, the
s of the sahab of the of the prophets,
we are nowhere. So if you read the
stories, your iman increases. If you
read the Quran, the translation of iman
increases and you come closer to Allah
subhana wa t'ala. Your ibada increases,
your salah increases, your s increases,
your fasting, your charity, your zakat,
all these things is these are signs. And
when do you realize that is increase?
You have peace of mind. Wealth cannot
buy peace of mind. when have peace of
mind that mashallah inshallah we are
following Allah and his rasool and
inshallah we will be raised in Jenna
with Allah and his rasool you know as
the prophet said that you'll be raised
with the people who you love so that
time the sabas were so happy they said
we may not be good indeed they were the
best after the
people who are the most blessed and the
closest to Allah subhanaa tala are the
sabas among the sabas number one among
Abu Bakr may Allah be pleased with him
he's number one then Omar if you hear
these stories and the lifestyle of the
prophet and the Sahabas you realize that
we are living in air condition we have
all the all the facility and yet we crib
yet we don't follow the sunnah yet we
don't follow the things that we're
supposed to do and if you read how did
the the Ansar the people of Medina The
Sabas of Madina helped the Sabas the the
muhajer who migrated from Makkah to
Madina and the stories it's phenomenal.
So the more you read the s and of the
prophet of the sabas your iman will
increase your practice will increase and
inshallah your peace of mind will
increase so that you're more secured
that Allah will give you the best in
this world as well as a hope that
answers the question regarding your last
part of the question that what if you
hear the punishment in the hellfire and
yet you're bothered about the worldly
things what is your state of iman even
after hearing about the punishments of
the hellfire. If you do not follow the
Quran and the Sai hadith and yet if you
continue worrying about the worldly
things that means your iman is weak that
iman is weak. I told you how your iman
is strong but if you hear if the two
things that makes your iman strong is
when you hear about the punishment you
fear it. So that's the reason when you
fear the punishment of the of the
hereafter of the hellfire the present
life for you the difficulties are
nothing they're peanuts so if after
hearing the punishments of the hellfire
or after hearing the rewards of ja yet
you continue and disobey the teachings
of Quran and sunnah that your iman is
very weak so that's the reason you
should be in touch with the Quran and
say hadith and these things will get you
closer to Allah and your soul. Hope that
answer your question.